so in the midst of everything going on
it with the virus the 2020 census is
also going on and there are already
discussions of does the census need to
be delayed what do we do I got my census
form last week and I filled it out I
have to tell you I don't know that I
filled it out correctly I don't know
that I answered the questions correctly
because of the way that a lot of this
stuff is structured I'll explain to you
my confusion I tweeted about this and a
ton of people opined on how I filled out
my census form so there's a question
which asks are you of Hispanic Latino or
Spanish origin now ethnically I'm an
Ashkenazi Jew with Eastern European
ancestry and I was born in Argentina I
my first language is Spanish I moved to
the US as an immigrant one of the
options for this question about being
Hispanic or Latino in origin is yes
another Hispanic for example Colombian
Ecuadorian and presumably Argentinean so
I checked yes I am Hispanic of other
origin and when it has you fill in the
detail I put Argentina so far so good
then it gets to what is your race white
black or african-american American
Indian or Alaska Native Chinese
Vietnamese some other Asian or some
other race now if you select white you
have to say what kind of white what
flavor of white are you and as examples
it says Irish or German of course this
is confusing because Irish and German
are also nationalities as much as they
can be ethnicities it could apply to
either it's sort of a mess now the
question of whether Jews are white is a
whole other thing you have a lot of
people who say Jews are white because
they pass as white although what about
Mizrahim and other Jews white
supremacists love to say no Jews are
definitely not white because if we say
they're white they're like us if not
white then it would be some other race
so in the end I put yes I am white and
for the type of white I wrote in
Ashkenazi Jewish did I do this correctly
should I have put in other race
Ashkenazi Jewish which of course gets to
Ashkenazi being an ethnicity not not
really a race so
in short I have no idea if I filled out
my own census form correctly but it's an
opportunity to remind you fill out the
census as of right now we don't have any
indication the census is being postponed
delayed or cancelled it's quick it's
really important I mean take it's five
minutes maybe I think it was more like a
minute 90 seconds
I know a lot of other things are going
on the virus people working from home
losing jobs etc when you get the form
take the 90 seconds fill it out you can
do it online or you can fill it out on
paper and mail it back and let me know
did I fail my own census form which
would be very embarrassing make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show we'll
be asking people about their census
forms you can also follow me at David
Pakman and I have a video of my new home
working set up where you can see all of
the monitors and everything that's going
on in here that's a on Instagram at
David Pakman one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I
use a virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman